our next two presenters met during the
filming of the boyfriend and last year
fulfilled their long-standing vow to
work together again this time live on
Broadway and George and Ira Gershwin's
my one and only here are tommy tune and
Twiggy
some Broadway performers wear their
costumes to the Academy Awards yeah and
you just met two of them we're here
we're here to present the award for
outstanding costume design and the
nominees are Joe I Tompkins but Cross
Creek Marek Voss for Fanny and Alexander
William where theis for heart like a
wheel
and Murray Marshawn for the return of
Martin guerre
Santo Lacroix Stouffer's le will never
know who the winner is
who would like to win everybody is there
one over there oh here it is and the
winner is Merrik vows for Fanny and
Alexander yes
married boss is working on a play in
Munich you can't be here tonight wheel
forward her Oscar to her with
congratulations
the great movie musicals were as
polished as they were because of the
lustre given to so many of them by our
next two presenters the all dancing all
singing all wonderful Jane Powell and
Ricardo Montalban who recently said the
Herve Villechaize Fantasy Island is
holding you back there our Jane Powell
and Ricardo Montalban
in Germany Jen and I are here to present
the awards for art direction the five
pictures nominated this year represent a
canvas as wide as the whole world and
galaxies far and far away the nominees
for best achievement in our direction
are Fanny and Alexander art direction by
Anna asper Return of the Jedi art
direction by Norman Reynolds Fred whole
and Jane shopping set direction by
Michael for the right stuff our
direction by Geoffrey Kirkland Richard J
Lawrence W Stuart temple and Peter
Romero set decoration by Pat pending and
George are Nelson
terms of endearment our direction by
Molly Platt and Harold Michelson set
direction by time ahead ago and Anthony
Mondello gentle art direction by Roy
Walker and Leslie Thompkins set
decoration by Tessa Davis asked for
Fanny and Alexander
or thank you so much I didn't prepare
anything to say but I can say that I am
very very happy to be here and to God
thank you